as coronavirus numbers spiked across
America California announces and
across-the-board shelter-in-place order
the Republican Congress pursues a
bizarre bailout policy and senators fall
under scrutiny for some rather
conveniently time stock sales I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
all righty so as you can tell we are now
broadcasting from the Shapiro hostel I
mean it is it is what it would a
beautiful beautiful place we now and
shelter an order place here in
California that means that people are
working from home as much as possible
and so we have transferred this show to
the bunker today's show is sponsored by
expressvpn my savvy fans secure their
internet join them and expressive VPN
dot-com / Ben we are here to provide you
with all of your coronavirus updates
where everything stands as we say we'll
get to the California lockdown in just a
second it is a statewide lockdown it is
enforceable by law so people presumably
will be pulled over and asked where they
are going if they're not going to the
grocery store or if they are not going
to the pharmacy then presumably there
will be given some sort of ticket it is
hard to imagine exactly how that's
enforced on 40 million citizens across
the state of California I'll get to that
in just a second first we begin with
your updated numbers as of this morning
right now there are fourteen thousand
two hundred fifty diagnosed cases of
corona virus across America suffice to
say those numbers are way too low the
reason they're way too low is because
tests are still not available it takes a
while for the tests to finally come back
anywhere from 24 to 72 hours and lack of
testing is making everybody's life
miserable
it is this stuff matters why well if
you're single and let's say that you
have the symptoms for kovat 19 and they
say okay go home go home just go home
the answer is okay I could do that but
let's say that you're a member of a
family let's say that you have as I do
three children and let's say that maybe
you think that somebody has the symptoms
for kovat 19 in your house and let's say
that you have child care helping out
because you have a newborn for example
and let's say that you want to go get a
test and it is impossible to get a test
well it's easy for them to say shelter
in place and don't go out of the house
and don't have any child care but what
if you still have to work and what if
you have to keep your children separated
from one another then what if now your
childcare is basically out the window
because you don't know if it's Kovan 19
or whether it's the flu if it's just the
flu then you can still have your parents
over if it's the flu you can still have
your nanny over if you but if it's not
then everybody is out and suddenly
you're on your own okay well that would
be my situation if somebody here came
down with the symptoms those situations
are happening all over the United States
people having an inability to let you go
to work do you not go to work do you
stay home how exactly do you separate
off members of your family how about
what if what if your parents want to
visit right how do you deal with all of
this okay the bottom line is lack of
tests
means tremendous lack of clarity and
that has incredible ripple effects
across the entire system okay so all of
this is being undertaken presumably as
I've mentioned 1,000 times before
presumably all of this is being
undertaken so that we can flatten the
curve and so I'm gonna show you this
chart one more time gonna draw it by
hand okay here is the chart that we are
supposedly pursuing right now okay this
okay so here is the supposed curve of
cases the high curve is the K the curve
of supposed cases in the possibility
that we don't do anything to flatten the
carb every just goes out and they do
what they want to do the line is medical
capacity so that would be the beds
that'd be the tests that would be the
ventilators that be the ICU beds right
all the things that you possible the
masks right that'd be the medical
capacity and then this flattened curve
is supposedly what is going to happen if
we stay home and if we all walk down and
if we all involve ourselves in social
distancing right this is sort of the
happy charts that has been presented to
you by the media as well as by the as
well as by the Trump administration so
across the board this is the chart that
is being used the problem is that there
are two questions about this chart that
people have yet to answer question
number one is the line actually here or
is the line down here okay because if
the line of medical capacity is not
actually over that shallow curve if as
it turns out you could flatten the curve
and the medical capacity line is still
all the way down here at the dotted line
it ain't gonna matter it ain't gonna
matter you can flatten the curve and
just as many people are gonna die and so
you will have shut down the economy to
no effect which is why what I've been
saying is the entire purpose of what we
are doing right now is to raise the line
from this dotted line to this top line
is to raise medical capacity so what
exactly are the plans to do that guys
and floating hospital ships ain't gonna
do it
adding a thousand beds by floating a
navy ship off the coast England and
cover it here adding a few thousand
ventilators is not going to cover it if
what we are being told is true that this
thing is super transmissible and super
deadly and all of that is true we need a
radical escalation in the number of beds
well those are those are the sorts of
estimates that the government should be
giving us right now have you heard
anything from the federal government or
from the state government in terms of
their prospectus in terms of increasing
capacity you've heard some numbers
floating around you've heard that there
are more masks floating around but
you're not seeing that on the ground you
have heard that there are more
ventilators floating around but you are
not actually seeing that in the hospital
so far as I am aware
heard that more ICU beds are being built
but so far I've yet to see any evidence
that massive new numbers of ICU beds are
being built so if we're not increasing
this dotted line to this top line it
will not matter whether or not you
flatten the curve okay then there is the
second problem the second problem is
that as you see this chart conveniently
ends at the right side of this piece of
paper right at the for you the the right
side of this piece of paper okay the
chart conveniently ends there what if
however this chart does not end there
now what I mean by that is let's say
that you release you lockdown procedures
and so now we are going to draw a
version of this chart that has a longer
time line okay so you have the original
curve you have the line and then you
have the flattened curve and then
everybody is let out what if the chart
instead looks like this okay so in this
chart for those who cannot see you still
have that same big spike it rises above
the medical capacity then you have the
track that we've been shown which
typically is said to end somewhere
around here right where my pen is right
this is where the chart always ends when
you see it in the media and when you see
it in the media and when you see it in
from the White House
all right the chart always ends at the
pen if there's gonna be a lower curve
it's going to somehow be below the level
of medical capacity and therefore
everybody is going to live what happens
if that's not what happens what I mean
by this is that what happens if in fact
you let everybody out of confinement and
instead of everything at petering out
the way it did on chart number one right
on the right side of this chart it
Peters out at the very end everybody
lives along happiness abounds everything
is great Prince Charming goes home with
Snow White everything's fantastic what
if instead of that you end up with
everybody comes out of confinement and
boom secondary spike which is exactly
what you are currently seeing in
Singapore you're starting to see it in
Hong Kong you're starting to see it in
Taiwan what if when you release the
lockdown measures it turns out people go
out and infect each other anyway and so
you end up with a secondary spike that
actually is close to it as high as the
first spike except there's still not
hurt immunity and you've not really
raised your medical capacity so what
that means is that what we really need
to be looking at is how do we raise our
medical capacity to this dotted line how
do we get our medical capacity up from
what is occurrence even if you think
current is sustainable to the upper
dotted line so question for the
government what is your plan
what is your
and if you don't have a plan why are we
doing any of this seriously that is the
big question
if we do not have a plan I said this
yesterday I am fine with locking things
down so long as there is a plan to raise
the level of medical capacity so long as
there is a plan for applying treatment
so long as we know that when we are let
out of confinement that we are actually
going to live in a world in which if you
come down with köppen 19 you don't end
up in a non ICU bed with an on
ventilator you end up dying on your
couch right as long as that is the case
as long as they are increasing capacity
then we can take a two-week break yes
it'll be brutal yes it will be terrible
but and it can't be interminable right
we can't do this for a month we can't do
this for two months that's not a thing
that can happen but the key right now is
we are not hearing anything like word
one from anyone in the government about
how they plant what what do those
numbers look like we keep hearing
estimates top level estimates a million
point one die if we let everybody out of
confinement okay do you have a plan for
500 thousand ICU beds like what exactly
is your plan here there nothing that by
the way that's the one factor that the
government supposedly can control the
government can't actually control the
rate of transmission the government can
do that for a temporary period of time
but people are going to leave their
houses people are going to go back to
work it's all fun and games until you
lose your job because as much as the
government says they're gonna float
these small businesses loans and all
this small businesses cannot survive
simply paying employees to be sick
without any stream of income and knowing
that there's gonna be a recovery on the
other side of this because the
government doesn't just the economy just
snap back in place immediately upon the
end of this thing people are gonna have
to go out again all those restaurants
that have been shut down you think their
clientele is gonna come back day one or
do you think that people are more likely
to order takeout for another year before
a vaccine is developed all of these
entertainment areas where people are
getting together in crowds do you think
people are gonna go to MLB ballgames
they're gonna go to the n-c-double-a do
you think that people are going to go
out into major crowds like Disneyland
will take a hit for two years following
this minimum right do you think that all
of that revenue is going to simply
reappear or our company's gonna have to
lay people off because of all this so
you can't say you're gonna fill
everybody's pocket with 500 bucks or a
thousand bucks but guess what that's
gonna pay for like a month like one
month and if you extended for two months
maybe two months and so with this
government lockdown comes the
possibility and this is what freedom
minded Americans should be thinking
about too with that possibility comes
the possibility of permanent huge scale
governments in our lives not going
away because if the government causes
the crisis and the government becomes
the solution to the crisis and the
crisis does not abate then the
government just becomes a permanent
feature of our life and the economy
doesn't go back to normal now again all
of this is an argument worth having if
and only if there is a plan to save
lives
but if the plans who save lives does not
kick in if all that's happening here is
the government marking time until they
let us all out of confinement we infect
each other anyway and all the old people
die then what exactly are we doing here
so how about some clarity the only
clarity we've seen so far is the
government demonstrating that it can
control our lives well we knew that
already we've seen no clarity on how the
government plans to actually lower the
death rates okay yes we can again we can
flatten that curve but there are two pop
there are two real problems with the
flatten the curves scenario one is if
our medical capacity is actually not
where the chart says it is it is all the
way down here if our medical capacity is
way lower than they say it is then
people are still gonna die and all we've
done is wreck the economy - no to no
avail or possibility number two there's
a secondary spike which is what most
doctors are saying there is going to be
in the fall anyway in which case if you
have not raised capacity by then then
we're screwed off anyway right and all
you've done is shut down the world
economy to achieve pretty much
absolutely nothing okay so what does
that mean that means that we need plans
from the government how are you going to
maximize the ICU beds how are gonna
maximize the masks how are you gonna
maximize the ventilators what are you
going to do to bring this to an end if
you have no plan to end it then you're
delaying things and marking time and
buying time is not buying time to any
effect right then you're in the
situation that we were yes president
from shutdown travel from China that was
a good move I am very happy the
president Trump's shutdown travel from
China that was designed to buy us what a
month or two and in that month or two
how do we do did we increase the number
of ICU beds no didn't increase the
number of ventilators no did we increase
the amount of testing no so what good
was it it was something good it slowed
it but the slowing of it is only good if
you don't hand up with the spike that we
are now attempting to forestall there
when we get to more of this in just once
I'm gonna talk some more case scenarios
some best case scenarios we're going to
talk about the government shutting down
the entire economy and whether that is
sustainable or not plus we are going to
get to at least several senators
involved in what looks like insider
trading on the Baths I mean just
horrible
ah you want to destroy faith in
capitalism and faith in government at
the same time this is pretty much how
you do it we'll get to that in just one
second first you know right now would be
a great time to change some of your
habits right you're at home anyway
you're trying to live out this economy
now would be an excellent time to change
how it is that you work how it is that
live and how do you live more healthy
right right you're worried about your
health right now because this disease is
coming from people with pre-existing
conditions well right now it'd be a time
to maximize your own health how can you
do that you can check out numa numa is
the habit changing solution that helps
users learn to develop a new
relationship with food through
personalized courses you can connect to
other new muses and build a healthy
community it's based in psychology neun
teaches you why you do the things you do
it empowers you with the tools you need
to break bad habits and replace them
with better ones Newman's not a diet
it's a healthy easy to stick to way of
life Noom has one of the biggest most
accurate food databases available that
lets you track meal habits visualize
portion sizes and see calorie density at
a single glance we're all strapped for
time this is why Newman's only gonna
take it like ten minutes a day okay it
is fantastic I've been using it myself
you may have noticed that I look a
little bit more svelte
well thank you knew him I really
appreciate you don't have to change
everything in one day commitment is more
valuable than bursts of productivity
sign up for your trial at noon and no
uncom slash Shapiro that is Numa com
slash Shapiro and start your trial today
what do you have to lose I mean really
it's not a lot of money and you can
change your life in a really significant
and positive way and om comm slash
Shapiro and oom Dom newm comm slash
Shapiro go check them out right now okay
so what are the best-case scenarios and
the worst-case scenarios here so
nicholas kristof believe it or not has a
pretty good column at the New York Times
talking about this best case scenario is
the possibility that the virus mutates
and actually dies out dr. Larry
brilliant I hope aptly named an
epidemiologist who as a young doctor was
part of the fight to eradicate smallpox
explained that only in movies do viruses
seem to become worse over time SARS and
Meers both petered out that is possible
here Kovan nineteen Wilmont survivors my
hopes at dr. Charles prober a professor
at Stanford Medical School China is
reporting not a single new case of
domestic transmission now there's
serious doubts about whether China is
lying or not if ever in doubt China is
Lyme trying to lie to the w-h-o and whi
believed them this is why when you hear
prescriptions from whu-oh or their takes
on life the WHL
you should really take that with a mage
or grain of salt
with that said according to Nicholas
Kristof Singapore would be the best case
scenario where everything is sort of
shut down for a while and then you go
back to a more open society Tom
Ingoldsby expert on pandemics at Johns
Hopkins Bloomberg School of Public
Health said the fact that Singapore Hong
Kong Taiwan South Korea and China in
some extent Japan have all flattened
their curves despite having the initial
onslaught of cases should give us some
hope we can sort out what they're doing
well and emulate at Washington State
seems to have been stabilizing the
weather may also help us because some
respiratory viruses declined in summer
from a combination of higher
temperatures and people not being
huddled together so it's possible that
northern hemisphere nations enjoy a
summer break before a second wave in the
fall ok that is that the second wave is
what I'm worried about
and I think most epidemiologists are
worried about is what happens when you
release people from confinement even if
this thing goes away during the summer
if it comes back with a vengence during
the fall it can be super damaging the
Spanish influenza which by the way you
know how ridiculous it is that our
political world somebody went on
Wikipedia and just changed it to the
1918 flu because they wanted to
forestall Trump's argument that you can
say Spanish flu so you can say Chinese
virus anyway the the goal would be that
maybe this thing dies out it loses sort
of its its fire and its flare also the
death rates I've been saying this for
weeks and I've been criticized for it
the death rates that were being put out
there by the WHL were just not real in
South Korea and in China outside who Bay
province about eight point eight percent
of those known to be infected died that
rate was 0.6 percent on a cruise ship I
talked about all of this weeks ago
that's not to suggest the virus isn't
dangerous it's very dangerous it's
significantly more dangerous than the
flu it is to suggest that people who are
suggesting that you know four percent
that people get it are gonna die that
was not true
about four out of five people known to
have had the virus had only mild
symptoms even among those older in the
90 in Italy seventy-eight percent
survived two-thirds of those who died in
Italy had pre-existing medical
conditions and were elderly and ninety
nine percent had pre-existing conditions
doctor Tara Smith epidemiologist at Kent
State said I'm not pessimistic I think
this can work she said it will take
eight weeks of social distancing to have
a chance to slow the virus success will
depend on people changing behaviors and
on hospitals not being overrun and
that's what I've been saying about
increasing that medical capacity now
there's the worst case scenario dr. Neil
Ferguson a British epidemiologist he
said he produced a sophisticated model
that showed a worst case of 2.2 million
deaths in the United States his best
case scenario according to Nicholas
Kristof is 1.1 million deaths which is
obviously frightening
as all hell the hope that the US can
emulate Singapore or South Korea could
be a leap because South Korea took the
epidemic really seriously they have a
tremendously effective testing it's very
widespread we are still as I mentioned
way behind in testing so far behind they
you end up with situations like Peggy
Noonan so Peggy Noonan from The Wall
Street Journal was sick with two weeks
101 fever coughs and chills and she had
to lie in order to get at covent tests
because right now the CDC the CDC still
has restrictions that suggest you can
only get a Cova test even if you are in
the most risky age demographic and you
have all the symptoms you can only get a
kovat test if number one you have been
traveling to China or number two you
know somebody who has been diagnosed
with corona virus which of course is
ridiculous since we've now had community
transmission in the United States for
weeks on end
which demonstrates the dramatic lack of
testing and that is the fault as we will
talk about of the CDC and at the highest
level of the trump administration
because in the end the buck does stop
with the president that doesn't mean the
president isn't doing the right things
now it affects said he is but it does
mean that those two months where the CDC
was blowing it heads need to roll over
there Nicholas Kristof says that there
is a an interactive model of the virus
that suggests that up to 366,000 ICU
beds might be needed in the US for
corona corona virus patients at one time
which is more than ten times the number
available there's a Harvard study that
has said the same how quickly can we
roll those things out that is the big
question we've heard no no estimates as
to how fast all of that is going to be
rolled out and that does raise the
question of how long are we going to
have to do this how long exactly is this
going to last and as I say you know even
this is a suggestion that there won't be
a massive second wave that takes out an
enormous number of people the fact is
that that in China which is now claiming
they tamp this thing down there are
serious questions about whether they're
lying about tamping it down in the first
place in California
the governor has now announced that we
are in a state of lockdown gavin newsom
on Thursday night ordered 40 million
residents to stay home except for
essential trips extending similar
restrictions statewide bay area counties
are previously enacted one of the
serious questions about this
particularly is number one whether it's
effective number two whether it is
designed to achieve the goals that they
say it's designed to achieve meaning
how can you lock people down this long
and the answer is it's gonna be very
very difficult a lot of people down this
long the stricter the lockdown the less
time it can last it's one thing to tell
people as I said yesterday about diets
it's one thing to tell people for the
foreseeable future no cookies it's
another thing to tell people for the
foreseeable future no food that's just
not something that people are going to
be able to outlast for a very long time
here is Gavin Newsom our Ken doll of a
governor announcing that it's time to
shelter in place in the state of
California number of days ago there were
six bay area counties that led with stay
at home orders now as I speak some 20
1.3 million Californians reside in a
community in a city and/or County that
have similar orders a state as large as
ours nation state is many parts but at
the end of the day were one body there's
a mutuality and there's a recognition of
our interdependence that requires of
this moment that we direct a statewide
order for people to stay at home that
directive goes into force in effect this
evening and we were confident we are
confident that the people the state of
California well abide by it okay so we
will see how long people abide by it
because you cannot tell people
interminably to stay in their homes
again especially as the economy dies and
these jobs do not come back it's very
easy for the government to say we're
going to freeze everything in place none
of these jobs will die that it's just
not true these are major systemic place
changes taking place throughout our
economy and they have significant
significant ramifications Newsom said
this is not a permanent state it's a
moment in time okay well then we need to
know how long the moments gonna last or
what your estimate of the moment is
going to be I was talking to panic
friends last night who have businesses
in the state of California and now those
businesses simply will not run because
nobody can go into the office and this
order by the way from Newsom is supposed
to last until April 19th okay a full
month how long do you think this is
actually going to last as we're now in
the star wars scenario as Princess Leia
says the struggle the more you tighten
your grip Vader the more star systems
Tarkin the more star systems will slip
through your fingers right this is where
we are the more the government tightens
its grip its grip the more there's gonna
be pushback against all of that
particularly as these law
mount we were hearing that we may lose
this week over two million jobs in the
American economy we are hearing
estimates that the economy may contract
up to 20% in q2 one-fifth of the
American economy poof disappears at the
behest of the American government so as
I say you want to make the case that we
ought to do that I need to hear a very
strong case as to how this is going to
prevent deaths it is not enough to say
that we're doing it to prevent deaths I
want to see the plan for preventing the
deaths I want to know how many beds
you're creating how many ventilators
you're creating I want to know how you
plan to stop the slow of this virus when
we all go back outside after a month and
when half of us don't have jobs really I
mean and by the way all of the
Republican relief efforts are Democratic
relief efforts are not going to fix this
problem they're not the best you can do
at this point is provided floating loans
to the banks to not call in their bridge
loans to to businesses back the
commercial paper window for example but
at a certain point people are not gonna
buy American bonds and number two what
makes everybody think there's gonna be a
v-shaped recovery the longer these
businesses are out the less a chance
there is that these businesses ever go
back in if you spent your life savings
to purchase a rib joint and they've been
running that rib joint for ten years and
the government just shut it down and
shuts down every restaurant across the
country effectively do you think that's
coming back anytime soon
and then $1,000 a month cheque is going
to suffice it is not and by the way
economics is real life when people say
well you're choosing the economy over
real life no economics is real life it
is people's jobs it is people
livelihoods it is how people live it is
the suicidality rate it is the it is the
sense of community this is not to argue
that we should be weighing the economy
against human life this is arguing and
we should always take the tack that is
most likely to preserve human life and
that would also include human quality of
life isn't that an argument we should
let everybody out right now I've not
made that argument anywhere in here
instead the argument I'm making is if
you are going to receive you are going
to do the most restrictive thing any
American government has ever done in the
history of the United States to the
American people right we're not in war
time here right it's a virus if you're
going to do this unbelievably
restrictive thing you better damn well
have a plan for how we come out of this
and that it saved lives because if you
just destroyed 20% of the American
economy and sent the unemployment rate
up to 15 or 20 percent and you saved
zero lives in the process
then I don't or there's a net loss of
life because it turns out that poor
people are more likely to get involved
in the opioid epidemic and and people
who have just lost their jobs are more
likely to feel despair and families are
more likely to break apart and all of
this and so you end up with a net loss
of life after all of this and people are
gonna be asking some serious questions
about whether this was in fact a smart
move or whether this was not in fact
some elements you better damn well have
a plan to increase medical capacity
above all of the possible curves because
if you don't then Americans are not
gonna stand by this they're just not
gonna stand by this we're gonna get to
more of all of this in just one second
first let us talk about how you can fix
that car it's sitting in your driveway
right now you're probably not driving
too much right now now would be a good
time to fix up that car I got a problem
with the part in your car you can't
exactly drive over to the auto parts
shop it's not open now would be an
excellent time for you to go to Rock
Auto calm get the part and replace it
yourself thank God for the interwebs
order your car parts online you can
limit contact instead of someone sitting
in your car handling your wheel after
doing the same for multiple other cars
and coughing into their elbow Rock Auto
comm is so much easier than walking into
a store and demanding quick answers to
things like is your Odyssey and LX or an
e^x and then they have to order the part
online anyway why not just do it
directly rockauto.com
their catalog is unique remarkably easy
to navigate rockauto.com has everything
from engine control modules and brake
parts to tail lamps motor oil even new
carpet whether it's for classic for your
daily driver get everything you need in
a few easy clicks delivered directly to
your door rockauto.com always offers the
lowest possible prices rather than
changing prices based on what the market
will bear like airlines do I spend up to
twice as much for the same exact part
rockauto.com is a family business
serving Auto Parts customers online for
20 years go to Rock Auto calm right now
see the parts available for your car or
truck right shapiro in there how did you
hear about us box so they know that we
sent you that is ROK Auto comm go check
them out right now okay so as I say I am
skeptical as to the capacity of the
government to actually do the things
necessary to raise the line so prove me
wrong government provement prove to me
that you can fix this problem the
government failed at ensuring that
people could get the test and as I say
that's having real-world ramifications
right now if you can't get a coronavirus
test and they're telling you to shelter
in place your life just got a pre
Shibley worse appreciably worse because
you don't even know whether you can
transmit this to other people and that
may be as I
a lot easier if you're single and living
alone but let's say that you're single
and you live with roommates
what are your roommates supposed to do
but that's a lot of people in the United
States what are you supposed to do for
groceries you're supposed to not go out
I mean like you need to go to the
pharmacy so now you have to have a
friend go to the pharmacy but we've also
been told that germs pass so easily that
if I hand you a plastic bag maybe it's
living on the plastic bag like if no one
can test then no one knows who the hell
is a carrier okay and that is exactly
why you have these social distancing
measures put in place by the government
but the only way to alleviate that would
be widespread testing in the mode of
South Korea as I've been saying for a
week now the goal here is to move from
the Chinese model lock everything down
to the South Korean model and even that
South Korean model is going to assume
that there's no second wave which may or
may not be true hey The Wall Street
Journal is reporting that when cases of
the new corona virus began emerging
several weeks ago in California
Washington State and other pockets of
the country US public health officials
worried this might be the big one
according to emails and interviews the
testing program they rolled out to
combat it was a small one limited
testing his blinds at Americans to the
scale of the outbreak so far impeding
the nation's ability to fight the virus
through isolating the sick and their
contacts and that is why you're seeing
these massive numbers rack up we should
actually be encouraged by the fact that
massive numbers are racking up because
that means the testing actually is
taking place as I say in the last week
alone in the last couple of days we've
seen a doubling of the number of
diagnosed cases in the United States and
that is simply because of the number of
tests taking place not because a bunch
of people just got the disease but as I
say this is the government policy that
is currently being pursued is not well
calibrated at least in the absence of
information as to what exactly they plan
to do I mean a good sign of this is that
the Trump administration is now asking
States to suppress specific unemployment
claim data the Trump administration is
now apparently asking state labor
officials to delay releasing the precise
number of unemployment claims they're
fielding an indication of how uneasy
policymakers are about further roiling a
stock market already plunging in
response to the corona virus outbreak
okay if you're asking people to hide
information and you're the federal
government that means things are really
bad like a lot worse than people are
telling you this is not a minor shock to
the economy this is the biggest shock to
the economy we have ever seen okay
including the Great Depression because
the Great Depression was an inflation
caused on the one hand or liquidity
crunch caused problem it was not
caused problem by a giant pandemic virus
that has not been alleviated in any way
and it was not the government forcibly
shutting down every business in the
United States it is never a good sign
when the Department of Labor is telling
people not to report unemployment
statistics that should scare the living
hell out of everyone and as far as the
plans to alleviate this crisis I'm sorry
but spending a trillion dollars this
month and a trillion dollars next month
and a trillion dollars the month after
that is not going to be a solution and
certainly what is not going to be a
solution is making these programs
permanent over time let me take a quick
example so apparently the bill that
President Trump signed into law this
week that was designed to get immediate
relief to people included a paid sick
leave provision according to the HR
specialist that I have talked to that
paid sick leave provision not only
mandates that businesses have to pay 14
days of paid sick leave when they have
no money on hand because they have no
income on hand it also mandates that if
you have a sick family member and you
say that you can't come into work that
you are supposed to you basically have
maternity leave 12 to 12 weeks of 60%
salary from your company how many
companies you think are going to abide
by that and what happens if the company
just says listen I'm not gonna do any of
that I'm just gonna fire you why do you
think unemployment rates are
skyrocketing why do you think companies
preemptively fired everyone before it
from sign that bill or went into effect
okay the government action here to
mandate the private business cover the
losses incurred by the government and
increased by the government is insane
it's why this isn't the bailout what the
government is doing right now this is
the government paying you back for what
the government is taking away from you
but the government is not capable of
paying you back for what it's taking
away from you because it's not just
taking away from you
the next month of business it may be
taken away from you the capacity for
your business to even operate at all
after a month is over because we don't
know what the hell is going on beyond
this so Senate Majority Leader McConnell
released a massive economic stimulus
bill on Thursday to fight coronaviruses
fallout and the and and this the
suggestion is direct cash payments to
many Americans the problem is its
means-tested based on your 2018 income
which makes no sense whatsoever because
guess what your 2018 income has nothing
to do with what you made this year also
by the way wait well let's say they made
$200,000 in 2018 when the economy was a
hell of a lot stronger okay and let's
say that today your business just went
bankrupt so you made $200,000 in 2008
so you do not get any money from the
government but now your business is
bankrupt and so you are bankrupt and so
you have no money and why are we means
testing based on 2018 income even means
testing based on today's income is
probably a mistake given the fact that
you have bills the means testing by the
way kicks out like a hundred thousand
dollars those people have bills to they
still have mortgages to pay so the
government solution is okay well we'll
freeze the mortgages well freeze the
evictions for how long are you gonna do
that and when that business is no longer
there do you think that the evictions
when they are unfrozen are going to take
its stock of the fact that your business
no longer exists Senator Lindsey Graham
is among several GOP senators voicing
concern or outright opposition to the
idea of direct payments even as
mcconnell unveiled the trillion-dollar
stimulus plan that would be the starting
point for negotiations with democrats
mcconnell called for the talks to begin
today a number of economists have
predicted the US economy is plunging
into recession the unemployment rate
could soar because americans are staying
home out of fear of it catching the
virus the centerpiece of the Senate GOP
plan would be hundreds of billions of
dollars sent to Americans in the form of
checks as a way to flood the country
with money in an effort to blunt the
dramatic pull back of spending that
ain't gonna work people are still at
home ok if you're freezing the mortgages
or if you are freezing the evictions the
best thing that you can do right now is
float actual
no interest loans to small businesses
via the banks that are already providing
those loans that is the best thing that
you can do right now because the biggest
problem here is banks calling in loans
on small businesses that are operating
on a day to day basis these these small
checks are simply like are they going to
help some people sure but one of the
problems here is that one of the other
factors in this legislation apparently
is that if you haven't paid federal
income tax then you also don't receive a
check back ok that's a lot of poor
people gang that's a lot of people who
may not be receiving the money the size
of the checks would diminish for those
earning more than 75 grand and phase out
completely for those earning more than
99 grand the poorest families would see
smaller benefits the minimum would be
set at $600 he had good luck in in not
breaking the economy based on this the
the vast majority of middle-class people
would receive a cash payment the
percentage doing so Falls dramatically
toward the bottom of the income spectrum
and none of this makes any sense the
Democratic plans make even less sense
because they are looking for permanent
plans that would basically turn an
enormous swath of human beings into war
of the state even after this crisis ends
and this is one of the problems every
crisis amounts to a dramatic growth in
American government involvement in the
economy if you're talking about the
biggest crisis in the history of the
American economy presumably that would
also according to Democrats mean the
most American government economic
involvement in the history and they're
and they're trying to make it permanent
House Speaker Pelosi and Senate Minority
Leader Schumer have slammed the stimulus
proposal they said it tilted too much
toward helping business even though the
vast majority of this is directed at
direct cash payments to individuals
Pelosi and Schumer said we're beginning
to review senator McConnell's proposal
and on first reading it's not Pro worker
it puts corporations way ahead of
workers by the way if those corporations
go under who is around to pay people
their salaries when this thing ends it's
the jobs disappearing that is the
problem yes the money disappearing for
the next two months is a major problem
the jobs disappearing is a forever
problem if those businesses go under
who exactly is going to hire the workers
this is how you get to Bernie Sanders
Federal jobs guarantee and the
government made this happen all by
simply declaring that the economy will
shut down now again you wanna say it's
temper you want to say you got a plan to
fix this thing and show me how it's
temporary and the plan to fix this thing
is actually gonna be effectuated
otherwise we seriously need to be
considering what the measures we are
taking here are the wall the wall street
journal editorial board has a good piece
on this today titled rethinking the
coronavirus shutdown they say financial
markets pause their slide on Thursday
but no one should think this rolling
economic calamity is over if this
government ordered shutdown continues
for much more than another week or two
the human cost of job losses and
bankruptcies will exceed what most
Americans imagine this will not be
popular in some quarters but federal and
state officials need to start adjusting
their antivirus strategy now to avoid an
economic recession that will dwarf the
harm from 2008-2009 the vast social
distancing project of last 10 days or so
has been necessary and has done much
good warnings about large gatherings
more than 10 people in limiting access
to nursing homes will save lives
the public has received a crucial
education in hygiene and disease
prevention even young people may get the
message with any luck the behavior
change will reduce coronavirus spreads
that were not overwhelmed but the cost
of the national shutdown are growing by
the hour and we don't mean federal
spending we mean a tsunami of economic
destruction that will cause tens of
millions to lose their jobs as Commerce
and production simply cease many large
companies can withstand a few weeks
without revenue but that isn't true of
millions of small and mid-sized firms
even cash-rich businesses
operate on thin margins and can bleed
through reserves in a month 100% true if
you are a profitable business that means
you had enough to pay your workers this
month and then you have a little bit
left over it doesn't mean you have a
multiple of your entire company budget
lying in a bank somewhere that's not the
way this works
first the lay off employees and then
have a necessity they'll shut down
another month like this week the layoffs
will be measured in millions of people
the deadweight loss in production will
be found says The Wall Street Journal
and take years to rebuild in a normal
recession the u.s. loses about 5% of
national output over the course of a
year or two in this case we may lose
that much or twice as much this month
alone Wall Street economist ed Hyman on
Thursday just at his estimate for the
second quarter - an annual rate loss in
GDP - 20 percent that is the entire
economy of the United States losing
one-fifth of its production
if GDP consensus seems abstract consider
the human cost think about the
entrepreneur who has invested his life
in the Memphis ribs joint I mentioned
this earlier only to see his customers
vanish in a week or the retail channel
30 stores that employs hundreds but sees
no sales and has to shut its doors or
the recent gradual is 20 grand in
student loan debt who finds herself laid
off from her first job maybe she can
live at home what if mom and dad don't
have a job or alternatively what if she
is 20 and her parents are 65 some of the
media who don't understand American
business say they're trying to manage
two comparable shock you have the
difference is that China's communist
country they don't care if a bunch of
people are out of work or die if they
cared about that there would be a
communist country the politicians in
Washington says the journal are telling
Americans as they always do they're
riding to the rescue by writing checks
to individuals but there's no amount of
money that can make up for losses in the
magnitude we are facing if this extends
for several more weeks after the first
trillion this month we're gonna spend
another trillion in April and another in
June and you can see this in the bond
yields who the hell is gonna buy this
stuff who the hell is gonna buy any of
this stuff by the way the market is off
again
today the market immediately upon
opening dropped something like 500
points the market continues to to drop
fairly dramatically and that is because
nobody feels secure here nobody is going
to buy up debt they feel is never going
to be repaid by the time the Treasury's
small business lending program runs
through the bureaucratic hoops
complete with ordering owners they can't
lay off anyone as a price for getting
the loan which of course is not going to
be a thing millions of businesses will
be
bankrupt tens of millions will be
jobless that's of course true because
you're not even allowed to lay anybody
often in the nut in the knowledge that
the next couple of years I want to be
super rough so you're gonna take that
loan only not be able to pay anyone
anyway and go bankrupt two months from
now perhaps we'll be lucky says the Wall
Street Journal the human and capitalist
genius for innovation will produce a
vaccine faster than expected or at least
treatments that reduce covered 19
symptoms barring that our leaders in our
society will very soon need to shift
their virus fighting strategy to
something sustainable dr. fowey has
explained the severe lockdown policy has
lasting 14 days in its initial term the
national guidance would then be
reconsidered depending on the spread of
the disease that should be the moment to
offer new guidance on what might be
called phase 2 of the corona virus
pandemic campaign and that will surely
include strict measures to isolate and
protect the most vulnerable are elderly
those are the underlying medical
problems this shouldn't be a debate over
how many lives to sacrifice against how
many lost jobs we can tolerate
substantial social distancing other
measures will have to continue in some
form for some time but no society can
safeguard public health for long at the
cost of the entire economy's health even
America's resources to fight a viral
plague aren't limitless and they will
become more limited by the day when no
one has a job when no one is able to go
out of the house meanwhile the White
House is trying to float 50 and 25 year
bonds to finance the stimulus packages
who the hell is gonna buy that like
seriously why would you buy a 50 year
bond because either you believe that the
economy is going to rise in which case
you wouldn't buy a 50 year bond you buy
stock or you believe the economy is
going to decline in which case why in
the living hell
would you trust the American government
to pay you back 50 years from now I
can't trust the American government to
pay me back five minutes from now forget
50 years from now the bond yields again
are up bond yields move in inverse
proportion to demand when demand for
bond yield for bonds is down the yields
go up the bond yields are up people
don't want to buy bonds they don't trust
the government right now now speaking of
lack of trust in government you want to
talk about dramatically undermining and
continuing to undermine trust in
government this story from The Daily
Beast is devastating senator kelly
Loffler apparently dumped millions in
stock after a coronavirus briefing she's
the second senator who got rid of her
holdings right as the stock market went
bad it turns out there for such senators
who got rid of their stocks as the stock
market went bad now some of these I want
to be accurate in the reporting here
our listing for example Senator Dianne
Feinstein among the senators who got rid
of stock the pattern of her selling
stock does not appear to be the same as
some of the more egregious apparent
abuses of the system
Feinstein serves as ranking member of
the Senate Judiciary Committee and her
husband sold between 1.5 million and 6
million dollars in stock in California
biotech company allergy and therapeutics
between January 31st and February 18th
according to the New York Times
Feinstein apparently was not directly
involved in the sale her assets are in a
blind trust according to her
spokesperson she has no involvement in
her husband's financial decisions
reports identified three other senators
James Inhofe Kelly Lafleur of Georgia
and Richard burr of North Carolina as
people who are selling vast amounts of
stock Feinstein's doesn't appear to
match the pattern simply because she
didn't actually make a lot of money on
the on the stock sale as opposed to and
the same thing is for vinho Loffler and
Richard Burr are a bit of a different
story
burr apparently was the chairman of the
Senate Intelligence Committee used more
than 30 transactions to dump between
630,000 and 1.7 two million dollars on
February 13th according to Pro Publica
that reports that the transactions
involves a significant percentage of the
Senators holdings and took place about a
week before the impact of the virus
outbreaks and stock prices plunging to
the point where gains made during
president Trump's term in office were
largely erased a burst spokesperson said
senator Burr filed a financial
disclosure form for personal
transactions made several weeks before
the US financial markets showed signs of
volatility due to the growing
coronavirus outbreak as the situation
continues to evolve daily he's been
deeply concerned by the steep and sudden
toll this pandemic is taking on our
economy on Friday the senator tweeted an
updated statement saying he relied only
on public news reports to guide his
decision on the sale he's asking for a
Senate Ethics Committee review of his
actions burr was an author of the
pandemic and all-hazards preparedness
Act a law that helps determine the
federal response to situations like
coronavirus outbreak first office would
not comment on what kind of information
burr received about corn virus prior to
his stock sales apparently burr made
ominous comments comments about
coronavirus behind closed doors at last
month he Senator February 27th meeting
of business leaders in Washington quote
there's one thing I can tell you about
this it's much more aggressive in its
transmission than anything we've seen in
recent history is probably more akin to
the 1918 pandemic
so supposedly the so supposedly Richard
Burr was getting inside information he's
a member of the Intelligence Committee
about the extent of the pandemic who's
telling people about it in particular
speeches he's not speaking super
publicly about it and he was dumping his
stock and insane rates he was not the
only one we'll get to more of this in
just one second first if you know if you
haven't had a chance to see some of the
new content we started this week called
all-access live you should head over to
daily wire.com you should check it out
Jeremy boring and I kicked off Monday
evening Jeremy and Michael moles
followed up on Tuesday night Matt Walsh
and Andrew Clemons had live streams the
last two nights I am planning another
stream tonight exigent circumstances
notwithstanding we will continue all of
next week at 8:00 p.m. Eastern and 5:00
p.m. Pacific if you're wondering what
all access live is about it's a lot more
relaxed than our normal programming
basically we're just hanging out with
you because we understand this is crisis
time it is very difficult for everybody
now we're all walking doors basically so
let's hang out together let's have a
good time these are live streams with
our audience they help bring us together
even if it's just through a computer the
show is intended for our all-access
members during this national emergency
and time of isolation we've opened it up
to all our members and in doing so
accelerated the launch so please let us
know what you think of it if you're
around at 8 p.m. Eastern 5:00 p.m.
Pacific tonight join us on all access
live over at Daley wire.com also
Sunday's special is back it is back and
better than ever this Sunday I have the
great pleasure of sitting down with
Hollywood mogul Jason Blum who's made
some my favorite movies including
whiplash he's also producer of the
horror series Paranormal Activity in the
purge we discussed his latest movie the
hunt which is now available video on
demand a thriller with some unexpected
political commentary that's this Sunday
March 22nd Hollywood created a certain
way information is consumed one of the
reasons Trump the President Trump was
elected was because the way that we
consume information has been changed by
the media industry across Hollywood and
New York
[Music]
so don't miss it we are the largest
fastest-growing conservative podcast and
radio show in the nation
[Music]
now meanwhile according to The Daily
Beast it's not just Richard Burr who's
in hot water over allegations of insider
trading
it is also senator Kelly Lafleur of
Georgia
apparently she sold off seven figures
worth of stock holdings in the days and
weeks after a private all senators
meeting on the novel coronavirus that
subsequently hammered US equities
Loffler reported the first sale of stock
jointly owned by her and her husband On
January 24th 24th the very same day her
committee the Senate Health Committee
who stood a private all senators
briefing from administration officials
including CDC director and anthony foul
at the head of the National Institute of
Allergy and Infectious Diseases on
coronavirus she tweeted appreciate
today's briefing from the president's
top health officials on the novel
coronavirus outbreak the first
transaction was the sale of stock in the
company residual technologies valued
between fifty and a hundred thousand
dollars the company's stock has fallen
by half since then it was the first of
twenty-nine stock transactions Laughlin
and her husband made through mid
February all but two of which were sales
one of Wilders two purchases was stock
worth between a hundred thousand and
$250,000 in Citrix a technology company
that offers teleworking software which
has seen a small bump in its stock price
since La Fleur bought in as a result of
coronavirus induced market turmoil la
fleurs office did not respond to a
request for comment from The Daily Beast
on the transactions and whether they are
prompted or informed by information
shared at that late January briefing
it's illegal for members of Congress to
train on non-public information gleaned
through their official duties that's the
reason presumably what Roberto is saying
yeah I was just trading based on public
reports the question is is that true or
is that not and how do you prove that
it's not true if it is not true
late Thursday night you offered a
statement you tweeted this is ridiculous
and basically a baseless attack I do not
make investment decisions for my
portfolio investment decisions are made
by multiple third party advisors without
my or my husband's knowledge or
involvement as confirmed in the periodic
transaction report to Senate Ethics I
was informed of these purchases and
sales on February 16th 2020 three weeks
after they were made now one of the big
problems here is that that statement
does not say that she was not
communicating with her husband or with
her investment advisors like I don't
actually handle my own investments
either but if I went to my investment
advisers they said guys I have some
pretty good information that this
coronavirus thing is gonna be a an
absolute bleep show and the economy's
probably gonna tank do with that what
you will and then three weeks later
like oh yeah by the way we got rid of
all your stock that week that's still
insider trading
okay that's still violation of law so
we're gonna have to find out what
exactly the communications chains were
here at the very least it looks very
suspicious in the week after her spate
of stock trades Loffler sought to
downplayed the public health and
financial threats posed by coronavirus
she tweeted on February 28th Democrats
have dangerously and intentionally
misled the American people on
coronavirus readiness here's the truth
Donald Trump and his administration are
doing a great job working to keep
Americans healthy and safe and she
tweeted on March 10th concerned about
coronavirus remember this the consumer
is strong the economy is strong jobs are
growing which puts us in the best
economic position to tackle covin 19 and
keep Americans safe here's the bottom
line anybody in Congress who is using
insider information to profit off of
coronavirus should not only be ousted
from their job impeached if they are
guilty of this again everyone should
have the opportunity to provide the
evidence there should be Senate in
ethics investigations on every senator
who involved in this that does include
senator Feinstein even if she appears to
be more innocent than some of these
other transactions which facially appear
to be pretty corrupt everybody should be
prosecuted to the full extent of the law
okay and nothing undermines faith in
both the private market and in
government like the sort of crony
garbage that it would be that these
allegations involve the sort of crony
capitalism that is involved in senators
trading on private information which by
the way the author Peter Schweitzer's
been writing about for a very long time
that sort of activity undermines not
only faith in government but in private
markets that is what that does it's hard
to think of a scandal more geared to
undermine public trust than a scandal
like this particularly at this time so
tucker carlson last night said that
senator burr should resign here's what i
say senator burr should have that ethics
committee check him out you know we have
to have due process in this country we
do have to have people provide their
side of the story and if it turns out
that the he can provide no evidence on
his behalf and that there is evidence on
the other side that he was calling up
his stock brokers or that he was in or
that he was talking openly with his
financial people about the implications
of coronavirus while publicly
downplaying it and selling stock at the
same time not only you should he be
impeached not only should be thrown out
of the Senate you should get whatever
the law can give to him in terms of a
prison sentence same thing holds true of
Loffler it holds true for anybody if
guilty if guilty
Shinzon their own are devastating I mean
really really damaging so this is all of
this stuff there's no good news today I
wish I could bring you good news the
only good news today is that the testing
does appear to be ramping up generally
across the United States we can hope
that the government is actually taking
measures that are designed to alleviate
the problem in the near term but if we
are looking at the Leviathan growth of
government because here's the problem
the longer this thing lasts the more
damage is done the more damage is done
the more permanent damage is done more
permanent damage is done the more
permanent government programs are gonna
be seen as the solution if you throw 20
million Americans out of work
unemployment benefits are going to be
made permanent I mean they just will if
you throw 20 million Americans out of
work there will be the Bernie Sanders
agenda starts to look a lot more popular
after you after the government forcibly
destroys the economy when the economy is
booming it's easy to say to people who
want to nationalize large swaths of
industry guys you really want to destroy
the economy when the economy is already
destroyed even if government did it in
the first place it becomes a lot easier
cell to replace the private economy with
something resembling a
command-and-control economy so gotta be
very careful all of this stuff must be
temporary and that means the shutdown
must be temporary and that means the
government Bennett get better get its
ass in gear because if this all happened
if we shut this whole thing down to no
avail
to not increase our capacity to not
lower the death rate then not only has
this been the biggest cluster F in the
history of American economics it has
been a meticulous attempt by incompetent
people to destroy the fundamentals of
the most powerful economy on the face of
the planet and that is devastating again
I'll go along with this program I think
everyone should go along with this
program for a period of time but not
without assurances that the government
is doing what it's supposed to do we're
all doing what we're supposed to do I'm
doing this from my from my house right
I'm doing the show from my house we're
all doing what we are supposed to do
better oh so all social distancing we're
all staying at home we're all staying
six feet away from each other we're all
doing it I am asking one simple thing
for the government to do its effing job
and if the government does not do its
job then not only is this thing gonna
get worse it's going
and I'm not talking about the virus it
is going to result in a completely
different America and that was not the
promise if the government the government
forcibly shutting down the economy to
take control of the economy would be one
of the worst things to I mean the worst
thing to happen in the history of
American government outside of slavery
and Jim Crow and overt rights abuses
like that so watch carefully the
government better come up with a plan it
better come up with a damn plan because
stay in place until further notice is
not a plan it is just not a plan
alrighty time for a quick thing that I
hate here so let us point out everybody
in the media is still focused on
President Trump calling this the Chinese
virus like stop just stop it's so
unbelievably stupid seriously if you
think the American people are sitting
around and just and just angry at
president from for calling of this
Chinese virus when the Chinese
government released this virus they did
they let five million people from MU
head around on full well there was human
to human transmission come on
so yesterday somebody took a picture of
the President's speech that he was
giving from the podium and he had
crossed out the word coronavirus and he
had written about the Chinese oh it
shows how evil it is oh it shows how it
was meticulous and how he's doing it
deliberately well yeah no bleep he's
doing it deliberately of course he's
doing it deliberately and guess what he
should be doing it deliberately the fact
is everyone needs to know that Chinese
communism resulted in the wide spread of
this virus that is what happened here
every step of the way from allowing
these wet markets to continue being open
for years on end after the release of
SARS after multiple diseases have been
unleashed from these wet markets not
only that they then censored anybody who
talked about this thing and they shut
down internet usage they tried to
prosecute people who talked about it
openly they lied to the w-h-o they're
probably lying right now when they say
that the economy is back on track in
China and that this thing is not
spreading in China they they certainly
could be lying I have a very hard time
believing that the the Chinese
government that was lying about this
thing back in December is suddenly
telling the blatant overt truth about it
they've locked it down man they've
really locked it down and if you believe
that I have a bridge in Brooklyn to sell
you but meanwhile there are a bunch of
people in the Democratic Party who are
focused laser-like I'm labeling this the
Chinese right how could Trump
to this thing how Susan Rice who busily
wide on American television about how
the Benghazi terror attacks were not in
fact terror attacks their response to a
YouTube video Susan Rice yesterday said
it's such a racist description by Trump
racist racist truly it's directed at the
Chinese government anybody who thinks
this is directed at Chinese people is an
idiot it has nothing to do with Chinese
people and has to do what the Chinese
government not doing the only thing that
it should be doing shutting down these
vectors of the I mean we're a free
government here in the United States we
have an elected government here in the
United States we have a non
authoritarian government and somehow
everybody is going along with the
lockdown of the American Way of life
China's an authoritarian state they
could even do this it's unbelievable but
apparently if you say Chinese virus it's
very bad according to Susan Rice
pathological liar certainly China is not
behaving well in trying to blame this on
the United States no but the flip side
of it is we are not behaving well when
we talk about as the President does
every day the Chinese virus the Wuhan
flu and all of these racist descriptions
the fact of the matter is that viruses
don't know borders they don't respect
borders so we need to get out of the
business of blaming people for where
viruses arise which can arise anywhere
on the planet and get into the business
of working together to defeat them okay
really like that so we have to work with
the Chinese government with we only work
with the Chinese
yeah like they've been working with us
the whole time right now they are
actively disseminating propaganda
information blaming the United States
government for the release of
coronavirus so spare me spare me it's
not just Susan Rice Aziz Tim Kaine the
former vice presidential candidate the
most forgettable vice presidential
candidate maybe in the history of the
United States remember that guy he ran
with Hillary Clinton you don't remember
him yeah I don't either Tim Kaine
senator from Virginia he says we have to
stop all of this China bashing really
they are attempting to prop again I mean
it's unbelievable here he goes with the
inflammatory China bashing did this
virus originated in China yes but mr.
president that does not excuse your
weeks and weeks of tweeting lies and
misinformation about the virus while the
leaders of other nations were taking
steps to make sure their populations
could be safe the
residents decision to call this China
virus or Wuhan virus or other epithets
that he and members of his team use are
a crass effort to deflect blame away
from the acceptance of responsibility
that a president should do the buck
stops with you mr. president okay but
the things started with China yes the
buck stops with Trump but guess what the
buck started with China so that makes a
rather large scale difference it does
make a rather large difference by the
way their polls out today from ABC News
about the president's handling of the
coronavirus situation he said about 55
percent approval rating on the
coronavirus situation which frankly is
kind of astonishing given the slow
response of the federal government at
the outset the response has been
significantly better as I said over the
last week and a half it's been
significantly better lately the federal
government better get to get its ass in
gear because those approval ratings
ain't gonna last if we're two months
into this thing everybody's still at
home and we haven't increased capacity
enough to get ready to go back to work
and every small business in the country
is under okay so move fast move in
concerted fashion because this the
current status cannot continue to be the
new normal it can and when I say it
can't I'm not talking about two months
from now I'm talking about a month from
now I'm about three weeks from now like
this is not going this is not going to
be the new normal Americans will not
take it nor frankly if they don't see
the prospect of lowering death rates by
a significant amount should they take it
alrighty well we will be back here a
little bit later today we hope with two
additional hours of content also later
today I am planning to stop by to hang
out with you like 5 p.m. today Pacific
time we'll hang out maybe talk a little
bit a Bible maybe talk a little bit of
entertainment sports is something we'll
figure out something to talk about so
we'll check you out then otherwise we
will see you here on Monday for all of
the updates stay safe in there not out
there stay safe in there and let's all
pray for each other and take care of
each other because this is a rough time
we'll get through it together
apart I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben
Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Colton Haas directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring
supervising producer Mathis Glover and
Robert Stirling assistant director Pavel
I douse key technical producer Austin
Stevens playback and media operated by
Nick Sheehan associate producer Katie
Swinton edited by Adam SIA vets audio is
mixed by micro Romina hair and makeup is
by Nika Geneva the Ben Shapiro show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 25 you know the Matt Walsh oh
it's not just another show about about
politics I think there are enough of
those already out there we talk about
culture because culture drives politics
and it drives everything else so my main
focus is our life family faith those are
fundamental and that's what this show is
about I hope you'll give it a listen